all right welcome back to amnesia the
Dark Descent I I uploaded a video to
YouTube just now and I realized it's
pretty pretty damn like dark you
couldn't see much I'm just going to
light it up a little bit it's going to
be a little less scary for me as well
and I feel like I kind of need that
let's stay in the light wow it's it's
gotta be more difficult though cuz I'm
gonna go insane for sure I got a slight
headache way I got that in real life as
well it's weird
oh yeah I was here and I I couldn't
figure it out but I think I figured out
when I did the better then I forgot
about it oh wait the end of that that's
awesome okay
because there were something called
Trinity yeah so that's got to be that
one and there was someone called for
face that's gonna be that one and flow
that's gotta be that one so I it's weird
that I remember remembering this and
then forgetting about it in the next
video yeah see now it's working I feel I
feel weird forgetting about
I thought one way which was the correct
way and then I forgot about this pretty
weird but I'm actually going to leave
this place if I can find exit which I
really hope I do by walking here because
I prepared the mr. part that's supposed
to be really scary so why the [ __ ] not
you know
because this place is the only parcels
anyway but there weren't that tricky
because I don't think it was field
stupid not figuring that one out but I
figure it out I figure it out when I
wasn't playing so I feel like it doesn't
care who gives a [ __ ] let's see if he
leaves me more presents he says he tends
to do that all that body's gone oh it
was the most I'm also I think it's in
the guest room I am not too sure there
was something really creepy about it
[ __ ] Hades [ __ ] prescence why
would I want this idiot doesn't even
work what am I supposed to you set forth
strange letter frighten him but it was
also the only one which offered some
comfort I already read that oh wow
I hope it's in here otherwise I feel
something about a painting I think
I already seen this these paintings
maybe it's not even here I don't
remember someone just sold me there was
creepy part in the guest room or
something
we're supposed to study I don't remember
I think these are actually the only only
rooms unless I'm missing a room
somewhere
I feel stupid wasting time on stuff like
these
yeah there's another key I would've
picked up the key that's pretty weird
and now the keys gone huh weird oh
that's
alright let's head out I think it's it
studying let's check that out well I
don't want to go in there take a study
is much much much more creepy yes I
remember it but let's do it anyway
disgusting
wait I gotta make sure my microphones
yeah it isn't you guys knew that what
you're laughing at me
[ __ ] no I'm kidding I love you
well left if your name is Jeff I don't
like Jeff I'm sorry sorry Jeff just
kidding I like Jeff's as well all right
I think there was
shake it out in here
might find some other stuff though I
don't remember yeah I've been here I
remember that
so I left the door closed that's not
creepy at all
it's sitting here nope
or if it's seen here cuz I never went in
here
oh this room is creepy
why should that stuff see I knew I
missed something let's see what you have
to offer
I already know that because dogs do that
star the show ho a mess
I should've sharpen the saw no sense it
it's definitely better douche I really
want to kill him now
douche honey I wish I could take this up
she saw his [ __ ] ass
oh poor doggy contro troll love you
beauty can we can we kiss yeah sure
I was weird I want to kiss him dead lots
of stuff to read animal experiment Canis
lupus familiaris 1658 April 2nd 12 of
April to April 12 I don't know [ __ ]
American system after a short study it
is it is clear that they are gay I like
how do I say that
agitation found among humans can be
found in the dog oh [ __ ] is agitation
fare and pain induced stress we seem to
trigger an endogenous response causing
the animal to burst with energy I
believe that the catalyst is produced in
the brain it is difficult to determine
exactly where and what it is but I can
sense it and it reeks of cosmic Genesis
there is an inherit problem in
harvesting there any distance the
creature is bound to die from the
exercise
I must refine this process of torture to
enable any real work to be done more
experiments must be performed but it
seems that only human beings are able to
produce the amount necessary it might be
their ability appreciate the server
severity of the process that ultimately
I meant their experience of terror
that's really horrible
so knowing that they're going to die
helps the process
apparently we found out that like
hundreds of people have been kidnapped
kidnapped to this castle and never seen
up again so apparently we didn't find
out why like they needed to kill people
but apparently they need the egg
contested it was called I can hate the
all here subpoena
it's nothing creepy about it
here's a book
I hate that guy [ __ ] Alexander is he
back okay and I tell me frontiers 616 58
January the 9th of January or something
further disappointment the antiquarians
laters finding yield nothing I'm still
unable to grasp the inner workings of
life and its relation to power I sense
within it I shall pursue more books on
this on the subject but I suspect it
will be in vain since no research has
been made in my particular interest i
must attempt to fill that void myself
clearly humans and men ate more of the
energy I seek but I hope animals will
suffice as they would prove less of a
hassle to acquire what a douche sheera
douche you know that oh what's your full
[ __ ]
mother of God [ __ ] [ __ ] you
[ __ ] [ __ ] Jesus Christ [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you burn [ __ ] burn
huh who's laughing now I [ __ ]
Jesus Christ you have a small dick
ah
oh thank you
all right aah oh my god
[ __ ] you making making funny faces that
me that's not it's not cool
[ __ ] cool bro I hate you I hate you
so much I wish I didn't go in here [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
I'm not going there [ __ ] you I'm out of
here
luckily [ __ ] [ __ ]
ah hate this game hate that [ __ ]
outlet side no [ __ ] I'm not gonna
bother reading that mother ah
I'm [ __ ] pissed and scared now that's
not a good combination [ __ ] douche
okay so back down and
[ __ ] the machine room I guess done
monsters there I'm gonna be sad and
viscous I'm [ __ ] tired of that
[ __ ] loss oh I wish I could just
[ __ ] kill it
it's okay I can escape
yeah kind of pop up when you don't even
expected yeah I'm a mess yeah she
stopped doing that [ __ ] [ __ ] okay I'm
done with the two parts I think it's
elevator should be running though but I
still want to check out this place yeah
it's probably maybe there's like an
on/off switch somewhere who knows
[ __ ] you box oh this has a nice glide in
it oh alright
maybe the mall series here hey there bro
[ __ ] you I hate you I hate you
you should know this oh I knew it oh
they're down another finite oil wait I
got some more
don't waste it Belle all right another
puzzle let's read this 17th of July 1839
powers this escaped me they're all dead
their limbs scattered head split down
the middle their skin flayed as it boils
I'm falling into myself what's happening
so William Smith professor Taylor now
dr. Tate is it following me oh how can
it not be it's the damned thing I
brought from Africa something is after
me no no I have no choice but to trust
the Baron
he'd better know what he claims if he is
wrong I suspect he'll regret it as well
but he already said that
you mean we got there missing cogwheels
to be fit that it
every time there's a postal douchebag
appears it's not my bro anymore whoa
more work all right
are now I have to find the parts missing
cogwheels it's a cogwheel
is it oh it's one of these this is
cogwheel I think we got to find those
here's one
it's pretty laggy
I'm being a [ __ ] I'm not playing in
full-screen anymore
is too much fun
I can hear your bro it's not cool I know
you're there